today workers have tried to recreate
Lady Gaga's iconic music video books the
makeup is always really intense Lady
Gaga is one of the finest lyricists of
our generation so we're gonna start with
the foundation it's kind of magical all
your insecurities just go away
I look like play-doh you're like cookie
dough it has the top six month that like
you can get addicted to
she's kind of got these crows Vil are
Kairos like what she has like a sexy
worm on her eyebrows and I look like I
have poop no these are frightening as
[ __ ] no it's just my hand is so chic oh
god is it tugging the other I lied well
I wonder my drag name would be I feel
like Daphne she's sassy but she has a
heart this is like open-heart surgery no
no this is the hard thing my worst enemy
it's amazing you just always just
default into this face reactions like a
grandpa like I look like nineteen
fifties thief who wears like you know
the stripes when you take your kid to
the zoo and they get like a really bad
bird painted on their face oh she has a
mole oh wait I have a mole are you gonna
emphasize it yeah
going on leaving people still use flesh
you look a little get cloudy first I
look cute now I look scary your goal
here is to cover my thin man lips as
best as possible
red orange oh that reminds me of
McDonald's no and so I think the key
with lips is not necessarily outline the
lips you have it's about a line the lips
you want my lips look like go-gurt
covering up is it got a big zit it looks
like I just ate at a fourth of July
feast and didn't give up then they
really pop out at you that's a clown
that I am ready three two one oh oh
maybe did a good job now she owns it
right
maybe if I owned this Noah didn't not
gonna be able to own this I look like
someone's weird grandma I think I look
pretty close this time - the eyebrows
she looks cute but deadly at the same
time right here but for me I just look
deadly a zombie clown and I'm about to
take you down cousin Jeremy this is Lady
Gaga talking to you at this point I
think my girlfriend would not only
applaud my skills but she probably is
gonna start asking me to do her makeup
this whole top is just a mess why didn't
we learn from today you do bad decisions
sometimes if I go out like this I hope I
have good enough friends to tie me up
and take me back inside it's really all
about your confidence and I think
everyone has it you just have to put it
out there I might come into work like
this tomorrow
I learned that guys guys so fun I hope I
did you proud go Lady gaga
what isn't art just like Lady Gaga or
art pop
[Music]